Italy's coronavirus epidemic already the
second most deadly after China has taken
another dramatic turn with more than 60
million people the country's entire
population under lockdown from Tuesday
Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte says he's
extending restrictions on movement after
another spike in deaths from the
coronavirus all public gatherings are
banned and schools and universities
closed until April the third note is
that a pool there will no longer be a
red zone they will no longer be a zone 1
and zone 2 in the country there will
only be Italy a protected zone so across
the whole Peninsula people should avoid
all movement unless they are for three
specific reasons for work emergencies or
health reasons 16 million people in the
north of the country have been under
lockdown since Sunday riots in two dozen
prisons across Italy followed
restrictions on face-to-face visits in
modernist six inmates died after they
broke into the prison infirmary and
overdosed on stocks of the heroin
substitute methadone as a warning they
posted some posters which say we can
only go inside wearing a mask they're
only allowing visits of one family
member at a time this was a hint of what
chaos might ensue if the virus were to
enter the confines of the prison system
it is almost everywhere else in Italy
these were rare scenes filmed inside a
hospital in the northern town of cremona
and also on lockdown the financial
capital Milan one of the engines of the
economy Europe's major stock markets
from Milan to Frankfurt Paris and London
all suffered dramatic Falls on Monday
with share prices plummeting as the
infection rate soars the economic impact
of the corona virus is already
substantial and will only grow there our
discomforting comparisons being made to
the 2008 financial crisis with concerns
for the preparedness of European banks
and businesses
on Tuesday EU leaders will meet to try
to come up with a unified response but
they won't meet here in person in
Brussels with its steadily growing
infection rate instead they'll be
holding a teleconference the
circumstances of this unique crisis
continue to evolve
although not yet into a pandemic says
the World Health Organization in which
transmission of the virus is
uncontrolled now that the virus has a
foothold in so many countries the threat
of a pandemic has become very real but
it would be the first pandemic in
history that could be controlled there
are signs of success against the virus
in China South Korea and Singapore but
not yet in Europe Spain looks set to
launch what's being described as shock
therapy measures possibly following
France and Germany with school closures
and restricted public gatherings these
are moves the government in Britain is
not yet prepared to make keen apparently
to defer the enormous social and
economic costs of fighting the corona
virus but there will likely be no
avoiding them Victoria Gaytan B al
Jazeera
ilaria Kapoor is a virologist at the
University of Florida and a former
Italian politician she says Italy has
one of the world's biggest ageing
populations making it more vulnerable to
this outbreak I think that the system of
reporting that is used in Italy is very
very different from systems that are
being used in other countries I think
that it is likely that infection from
Asia did not reach Italy only but it
reached a series of European countries
and that there have been intro European
circulation of the virus and Italy is
one of the countries infected by the
corona virus
it certainly has had a significant
number of hospitalized patients but
Italy has a significant aging population
we are one of the old the countries with
the longest life expectancy plus the
public service we'll take on any case
and therefore I think that this is quite
a unique situation compared to the rest
of the world I don't think that the the
virus when it left before the Wuhan
lockdown went only to Italy there are as
I said many many connections in Europe
with China but also in Africa with China
and so I suspect that the infection
might be more widespread than what is it
is currently believed to be